[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos se preguntan si es posible hacer
compatible el islam con la democracia y
los derechos humanos lo cierto es que
hay muy pocos ejemplos para ser
optimistas incluso en turquía donde la
separación entre iglesia y estado está
garantizada por la propia constitución
parecen estar dando pasos cada vez más
rápido hacia lo que sería una teocracia
islámica sin embargo hay un país que
escapa de esta tendencia y ese país es
túnez
esta república de poco más de 10
millones de habitantes fue el lugar
donde empezaron las llamadas primaveras
árabes que nunca ha entendido por qué
las llaman primaveras cuando en realidad
empezaron en enero lo cierto es que fue
aquí concretamente en la ciudad de sidi
bouzid donde un frutero de 26 años se
quemó a lo bonzo en una protesta en
frente de un edificio del gobierno así
es como comenzó una revolución que se
extendió por todos los países del norte
de áfrica
el resto de la historia ya la conocemos
en egipto consiguieron derrocar a su
dictador pero al final han terminado
volviendo a otra dictadura militar igual
o peor que la que tenían antes
libia es un estado fallido con riesgo de
caer en manos del integrismo islámico y
de sería mejor no hablar
sin embargo túnez es la excepción que
confirma la regla tras deponer a su
dictador abidine benalí los tunecinos
redactaron una constitución que reconoce
la libertad de expresión y la libertad
de culto no sólo eso además el 20 por
ciento de los escaños del parlamento
tunecino están ocupados por mujeres lo
que supone un paso de gigante en esta
región
y precisamente por eso túnez se ha
convertido en uno de los principales
objetivos del da es que ya lleva
asesinados a más de 73 personas en tres
atentados terroristas así que la
pregunta es será capaz de sobrevivir la
democracia tunecina puede llegar a
convertirse en un modelo para el resto
de países islámicos hoy vamos a
responder a esta pregunta y además vamos
a hablar del rol que tiene la unión
europea en toda esta historia que puede
ayudar o dinamitar todo el proceso
democrático en túnez pero antes vamos a
ver un poco de perspectiva histórica
[Música]
y sombras de abidín benalí en 1955 túnez
se independizó de francia al igual que
casi todos los países de la región
túnez se apuntó al llamado socialismo
árabe o panarabismo que es un cóctel
ideológico que mezcla economía
planificada líderes autoritarios muy
carismáticos y por supuesto secularismo
incluso si me lo permitís una actitud
bastante beligerante con la religión
especialmente con el islam esta
corriente ideológica fue muy popular en
la zona y nos ha dado a líderes tan
populares como muamar el gadafi en libia
o nasser en egipto
en el caso de túnez su presidente sería
este señor que vemos aquí que se llamaba
habib burguiba por hacer un resumen su
gobierno estuvo marcado por el
clientelismo la corrupción y continuas
devaluaciones de la divisa tunecina el
dinar que terminaron por dar al traste
con la economía tunecina el resultado
que en 1987 y con una crisis financiera
bestial
aprovechando que burguiba estaba en el
hospital recuperándose de un infarto su
primer ministro le robó el sillón
presidencial y se hizo con el gobierno
en lo que llaman el golpe de estado
médico no hubo el más mínimo atisbo de
violencia es más cuando burguiba salió
del hospital abidine benalí le mandó a
una residencia de lujo con médicos y
enfermeros que pudieran cuidar de él
no sólo eso además cuentan que hasta el
día de su muerte ben alí le visitaba
frecuentemente para ver cómo estaba
vamos que aquello fue un golpe de estado
pero con cariño y os preguntaréis qué
hizo abidine benalí como gobernante de
túnez durante su presidencia prometió
varias veces que traería la democracia
al país y lo cierto es que convocó
elecciones en varias ocasiones el
problema es que los partidos políticos
que quisieran presentarse necesitaban
como mínimo 30 firmas de miembros del
propio gobierno de ben alí
esto significa que en muchos casos la
única candidatura que podía presentarse
a unos comicios era o sorpresa la de su
propio partido gracias a esta peculiar
interpretación de la democracia ben alí
se mantuvo en el poder durante más de 23
años 23 años que por supuesto estuvieron
marcados por la misma corrupción y
clientelismo a la que los tunecinos
estaban ya tan acostumbrados sin embargo
hay una cosa que sí que le tenemos que
reconocer a nuestro amigo abidine benalí
y fue su pragmatismo a la hora de pensar
la política económica
desde el primer momento entendió que
tenía que abrirse a la inversión
extranjera y permitir que empresas de
otros países pudieran establecerse en su
territorio así es como llegaron varias
cadenas hoteleras atraídas por el buen
clima y las playas de túnez y así es
como el turismo se convirtió en la
primera industria de túnez seguida del
cultivo del olivo y quedaros con esto de
los olivos porque luego vamos a hablar
de ello lo cierto es que durante estos
20 años los tunecinos multiplicaron su
riqueza por tres y de hecho en el año
túnez recibió a 6 millones de turistas
que es la mitad de lo que recibe su
vecina egipto con la diferencia de que
egipto tiene las pirámides y nueve veces
más población quedaros con esta cifra
porque también es muy importante
túnez es un país de 10 millones de
habitantes que ha llegado a recibir 6
millones de turistas en solamente un año
y por thiago tanto énfasis en este punto
pues porque los turistas no solamente
dejan dinero en el país sino también
cultura de repente en túnez se convirtió
en algo normal ver a mujeres
occidentales pasear sin tener la cabeza
cubierta a parejas homosexuales dándose
la mano por la calle o incluso a gente
bebiendo alcohol es decir ningún otro
país de la zona ha estado tan expuesto a
otras formas de vida como lo ha estado
tú y por eso si eres uno de esos
españoles que se ha emborrachado alguna
vez en un hotel tunecino durante un
viaje de fin de carrera enhorabuena
puedes decir que pusiste tu granito de
arena para abrir la sociedad tunecina
gracias a eso han podido ocurrir cosas
como esta
[Música]
democrática en túnez en el año 2010 la
economía tunecina estaba on fire pero
sin embargo la tasa de desempleo estaba
por encima del 12% a todo esto hay que
sumarle los escándalos de corrupción y
los abusos de poder por parte del
gobierno de ben alí que no se publicaron
en la prensa local pero sí en los
periódicos extranjeros incluidos el país
en españa' y esto motivó varias
protestas en distintas ciudades
probablemente estas manifestaciones no
hubieran llegado a ninguna parte si no
hubiera sido por el joven mohamed
buazizi un frutero de 26 años que se
quemó a lo bonzo después de que la
policía confiscara su negocio de venta
ambulante
y así es como se inició lo que los
periodistas llamaron la 'revolución de
los jazmines' de repente todas las
ciudades tunecinas se llenaron de
manifestantes y a diferencia de otros
dictadores abidine benalí no opuso la
más mínima resistencia
en alguien se retira tras 23 años en el
poder y abandona túnez a partir de este
momento el presidente del parlamento
formó un gobierno provisional y liberó a
más de 500 presos políticos no sólo eso
además todos los disidentes tunecinos
que estaban repartidos por el extranjero
regresaron al país entre otros este
señor que vemos aquí que se llamaba
moncef marzouki que por aquel entonces
era el presidente de la comisión árabe
de los derechos humanos pero la cuestión
cómo estuvo esa pregunta que se estarán
haciendo es si en túnez estamos hablando
sobre islamismo la respuesta es no be
democracy ned estamos hablando sobre
democracia tan sólo un año después de
que bauzá si se prendiera fuego
túnez estaba celebrando sus primeras
elecciones libres y así es como nuestro
amigo marzo aquí se convierte en el
presidente del país el problema que el
primer ministro es del partido islamista
[Música]
hablamos del llamado movimiento ennahda
que es algo así como la versión tunecina
de los hermanos musulmanes aunque un
poquito más moderada en un momento en el
que se acababan de legalizar más de 100
partidos políticos en acta era el único
movimiento bien estructurado y con unos
líderes claros y por eso este partido
ganó la mayoría de los escaños del
parlamento y no olvidéis que este
parlamento era el que tenía la misión de
redactar la nueva constitución tunecina
[Música]
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es no respect una banda de nu
metal de lima en perú que nos ha mandado
su música si os gusta encontrareis más
enlaces de ellos en la descripción
y os preguntaréis con este panorama cómo
es posible que la constitución de túnez
sea laica lo cierto es que en este
momento de tanta incertidumbre política
los sectores islamistas más radicales
formaron lo que llamaron las ligas
islámicas que por supuesto estaban
apoyadas por el primer ministro que
quería islamizar el país a marchas
forzadas esto significaba vandalismo en
las calles mucha violencia y lo que es
peor
[Música]
los líderes de la oposición mohamed
hamid y suscribe light asesinados con la
misma pistola mientras tanto los
ingresos del turismo en este país caían
en picado lógicamente nadie quiere
viajar de vacaciones a un sitio tan
peligroso y eso generó aún más malestar
social ante este panorama el resto de
partidos políticos laicos formaron un
frente común contra enahda y su primer
ministro
y así es como este bloque islamista no
le queda más remedio que aceptar en su
gabinete de ministros a otros políticos
de otros partidos y esto significa que
en poquitos meses tanto las ligas
islámicas como los hermanos musulmanes
en egipto pasan a ser considerados como
grupos terroristas lógicamente los
islamistas más radicales abandonarán el
gobierno en este momento y poco más
tarde lo harían los demás miembros
islamistas más moderados que dejaron
todo el poder de decisión a los partidos
más laicos a cambio solamente de una
cosa y es que reconocieran en la nueva
constitución al islam como religión
oficial el resultado que la nueva
constitución tunecina no sólo reconoce
la libertad de expresión sino también la
libertad de culto no sólo eso también
garantiza una educación imparcial no
religiosa y si el islam mantiene un
estatus totalmente simbólico pero el
país se rige por leyes totalmente laicas
y así es como surgen nuevos periódicos y
una sociedad civil muchísimo más fuerte
en cualquier otro país del norte de
áfrica y por eso cuando se convocan
elecciones de nuevo en el año 2014 los
islamistas pierden frente a este frente
que habían formado todos los partidos
laicos y liberales que se llamaba unida
túnez
[Música]
y para que os deis cuenta de la
influencia que juega el turismo en la
sociedad tunecina mirad este mapa con
los resultados electorales de los
últimos comicios si os fijáis los
islamistas pierden en todas las zonas de
playa que es donde están los hoteles y
dónde está la gente que se dedica al
turismo sin embargo ganan en las
regiones más rurales que es donde
todavía el turismo no tiene esa
influencia pero esperad un momento
porque las cosas no son tan bonitas como
nos gustaría
[Música]
quien amenaza la democracia en túnez tan
solo unos meses después de que túnez
apruebe su nueva constitución el daes o
el estado islámico organiza un atentado
en el museo del barrio que es una de las
principales atracciones turísticas de
este país a este país le siguen otros
dos atentados en total 73 muertos pero
no sólo eso
como el resultado el número de turistas
británicos que solía batir récords en
los primeros meses del año ha caído en
un 93 2% así que el nuevo gobierno de
túnez no solo tiene que lidiar con
problemas de seguridad sino también con
una crisis económica que está
destruyendo la principal industria del
país y por eso noticias como estas son
tan importantes
[Música]
túnez ofrece a los inversores
extranjeros proyectos por valor de 50
mil millones de dólares no sólo eso la
unión europea ha eliminado los aranceles
que había a la importación de aceite de
oliva tunecino ya sabéis que la unión
europea la agricultura está protegida
del extranjero con muchísimos impuestos
pero en el caso de túnez es crucial
apoyar la industria del olivo que como
hemos visto es la segunda más importante
de todo el país pero esperad un momento
porque ya os podéis imaginar cuál es la
respuesta de los agricultores europeos
especialmente los italianos
salvemos nuestra excelencia no al aceite
tunecino esto es especialmente gracioso
si tenemos en cuenta que buena parte de
ese aceite made in italy en realidad
está hecho en túnez y después etiquetado
en italia y aquí es donde empieza la
batalla política en europa porque por un
lado es crucial rescatar la economía
tunecina para que puedan mantener su
democracia pero por el otro muchas
empresas europeas no están dispuestas a
perder sus privilegios
[Música]
así que la pregunta es creéis que la
unión europea tiene que abrir su mercado
con túnez para que puedan mantener su
democracia y por otro lado creéis que
túnez puede llegar a convertirse en un
modelo para sus países vecinos podéis
dejarme vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios y no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones como
siempre si alguien quiere profundizar
más en este tema encontrará varios links
en la descripción si os ha gustado este
vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
[Música]
[Aplausos]